If you want to learn how you can win a free
CZsWorld hoodie to keep you warm this holiday
season then stick around to the end of this
video.
Welcome to a very Merry episode of Things
You Missed, cause today we’re coving the
2006 version of Black Christmas.
So really it’s not too Merry at all.
If you’re looking for a happier holiday
video, go watch my episode on the original
movie, but if you’re staying here then let’s
get into the Things You Missed.
[THINGS YOU MISSED]
At the beginning we see Claire writing in
red ink, drinking red wine… wait -- don’t
go in the closet Claire.
Red means dead!
Don’t go in the -- why does nobody EVER
LISTEN TO ME!
In this movie we are shown a bit more backstory
about the killer, Billy.
We first meet him confined in a facility known
as the Clark Sanitarium.
This is an homage to Bob Clark, the man who
directed the original 1974 version of Black
Christmas, but that’s not the only tribute
to him in the movie.
Black Christmas is not the most well known
Christmas movie that Clark has directed, because
he also directed the comedy, A Christmas Story
in 1983.
The most iconic prop from that movie, really
one of the most iconic props from any movie,
is the Leg Lamp that Mr. Parker wins in a
contest, much to the dismay of his wife.
“I know just the place for it.
Right in the middle of our front room window!”
“Uh?”
In Black Christmas, the lamp can be seen in
the background in the girls’ living room.
But that’s not the only A Christmas Story
reference seen in the movie.
When Ralphie finally gets his BB gun for Christmas
and shoots his eye out, his glasses end up
saving him, so he makes up a story for his
Mom about how an icicle came down and broke
the spectacles.
Roll it.
“And I tried to get out of the way.
But I..."
"There. See? It's just a little bump.
You're OK.
You're lucky it didn't cut your eye,
those icicles have been known to kill people.”
Well there just so happens to be one victim
in Black Christmas who isn’t murdered by
anyone, but rather falls prey to a deadly
icicle.
That’s Mrs. Mac, the house mother.
She’s played by Andrea Martin, who graduated
to that role after playing one of the sorority
girls, Phyl, back in the original Black Christmas.
This next one isn’t my own discovery, but
I saw something online about it so I thought
I’d give it a mention.
Each one of the girls is named after a singer
who made a well known Christmas song:
Kelli Presley for Elvis Presley
Melissa Kitt for Eartha Kitt
Dana Mathis for Johnny Mathis
Clair Crosby for Bing Crosby
Leigh Colvin for Shawn Colvin
Megan Helms for Bobby Helms
And finally….
Heather Fitzgerald for Ella Fitzgerald
I think that’s enough Christmas music for... for like ever.
One thing that this remake does that I liked
was have elements of the original, but the
script is totally different.
Some of those elements include Agnes and Billy,
using plastic wrap for a kill, having the
killer setup shop in the attic, using the
disturbing phone calls made from inside the
house to frighten the girls (this time using
each victim’s cell phone because those exist
now)
"Can you hear me now?"
*horror screams*
"Good."
...the weapon used in Billy’s most iconic
kill from the original movie is shown to be
a gift given in the girls’ secret Santa
exchange…
“Oh thanks Eve.
That’s… that’s so sweet.
On a side note, Eve is the name of the girl
who delivers the murder weapon on Christmas
Eve?
That sounds possibly intentional but not really that
interesting.
And most notably, making the killers obsessed
with eyes and peepholes to give more meaning
to the most iconic shot from the original.
Eyes continue to show up throughout the movie
for seemingly no reason though, like some
of the wall artwork and Megan’s screensaver.
Speaking of Megan’s computer…
I don’t think it’s entirely clear what
is going on when Kyle shows up, so let me
run though that subplot really quick.
Kyle is shown to be dating Kelly.
When she gets out of the car, he gets on the
phone with Megan.
We don’t hear the conversation, but we later
see Kyle in a video with Megan.
Let’s just say it would end up in the adult
section of the video store had it been the
pre-internet days.
Kyle probably doesn’t want his girlfriend
to find out, so we can assume that’s what
the earlier argument was about.
He later climbs into Megan’s room, probably
to confront her about it, maybe to steal back
the video, but he gets caught, and tells his
girlfriend he was trying to climb into her
room, but the window was closed, so he went
into Megan’s instead.
Then in the background, and this is only on
screen for a moment, it seems that Megan has
posted the video on a message board called
C Pupils, which I guess specializes in home
made videos from college students.
The users of this site look like perfectly
normal, well-adjusted individuals.
Also, one other note on Megan’s room, she
has this poster for a Raveonettes concert
with an insane looking depiction of the male
/ female rock duo, a clue that the antagonists
of this movie would also be a mentally depleted
guy / girl team: Billy and Agnes.
When we see into Billy's childhood the first present he gets is a satellite.
and the other one is a telescope,
both things that fit into the theme of surveillance
and voyeurism.
We see how Billy gets his peephole kink from
a very young age, he watches his parents fight
through door cracks and holes in the architecture.
When Heather find the collection of newspapers
hidden in the wall, there’s an article about
the night that Billy attacked his family on
Christmas, where we see the origin of the
movie’s title.
The massacre was dubbed by the media as “Black
Christmas”.
After Kelly and Leigh make it out of the house
to the hospital, is what I think is the most
horrifying part of the movie.
I mean I guess they felt like they had to fit in
the Christmas carolers from the original film
somehow, so they got a bunch of grown
adults dressed like some steampunk 1930s lookin
thing and THIS!?
I mean this should be the killer.
This is terrifying!
I anyway, I don’t have anything else for
this one, if you haven’t seen it, it’s
more gross than it is scary, so I’m not
really into that.
But I do have something for you, it’s
a little holiday gift to keep you warm during
your Christmas-horror movie marathons this
December.
I’m giving away a CZsWorld hoodie -- all
you have to do to get your hands on it is
follow me on Instagram and like this post.
Full rules are in the description.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.